[Música]
bom pessoal como estava falando com
vocês nós somos do projeto trilha do
saber e nós vemos aqui compartilhar uma
grande ideia que na verdade é um fato o
fato de que brincar ensina
lembrei de quando vocês eram crianças e
que vocês estavam na escola
e aí imagina que chega um professor ou
uma professora e dizer 'você só a partir
de agora nós vamos aprender através de
brincadeiras maravilhoso né
imagine uma disciplina como a matemática
é uma disciplina que muitos consideram
de difícil compreensão e imagina ela
sendo apreendida através de jogos é um
pouquinho sobre isso que a trilha vem
compartilhar com vocês
quando vocês estavam lá na escola e
chegava o professor de matemática o pi
falava vou ensinar matemática uma
expressão que muitos de vocês tinham é
essa dessa menina de medo susto
apreensão
mas aí quando vocês iam por exemplo
jogar um jogo como amarelinha
eu sei que é um jogo que alguns de vocês
chegaram a brincar era fácil de entender
e de aprender a contar de 1 a 10 e
entender que o 7 é maior que os 5
entender que o 3 é maior que 1 porque
vocês jogavam a pedra e tinha que pular
sentir com o corpo os números então era
fácil entender a matemática se ela
estivesse dentro de um contexto há mais
ou menos duas décadas
três pesquisadores da universidade
federal de goiás que são barreto borges
de menezes elas investigam estudam
tecnologias de entretenimento no ensino
da educação matemática então elas
estudam e publicaram um artigo em 2015
falando sobre a importância do jogo
a ação e principalmente na educação
matemática e quando falo de jogo eu tô
falando de jogos não só os jogos de
tabuleiro jogos físicos como os blogs
games mas eu tô falando também de jogos
digitais aplicativos aqueles jogos que
vocês pegam lá nuno gostou do google
play e jogam videogames entre outros
jogos
então essa foi preciso que elas
publicaram aí pessoal agora um desafio
pra vocês
imagine dois cenários o primeiro cenário
que é esse que vocês visualizam imagina
o joãozinho e indo à feira comprar
frutas e verduras
ele vai à feira e compra frutas e
verduras é um problema matemático
vamos pensar sobre isso ele vai à feira
comprar frutas e verduras
a banana custa 5 reais ea maçã custa 2
ele comprou uma banana e duas maçãs
quanto gastou
joãozinho isso é o primeiro cenário
imaginem esse cenário agora imagine o
segundo cenário que é esse cenário onde
o joãozinho na verdade pilotando um
boeing está lá dentro da aeronave
conduzindo a aeronave com o painel de
controle com gráficos e indicadores
índices da matemática
agora pára e pensa em uma pergunta pra
vocês que vocês consideram que é o
cenário mais real para a criança que é o
cenário mais importante de aprendizado
para a criança
vocês acreditam que é o joãozinho que
vai à feira comprar frutas e verduras
ou vocês acreditam que é o joãozinho que
pilota uma bomba em uma aeronave não
precisa responder
acredito que vocês já estão respondendo
mentalmente mas realmente como a
psicologia diz ea pedagogia entre outras
áreas de estudo de desenvolvimento
infantil
o cenário ideal para a criança aprender
é aquele cenário onde ela fantasia onde
ela tem um imaginário onde nesse
imaginário infantil ela tem uma
maturação cerebral e através dessa
maturação se
brown ela vai aprender e vai se
desenvolver no mundo
aí eu estou falando que brincar ensina e
eu estou falando de matemática
eu trago para vocês uma função eu tô
vendo no rosto aí de alguns e
provavelmente o pessoal também está em
casa
uma função que eu trago é como vocês
estão vendo
parece uma função complexa mas o pessoal
aqui que é da área de exatas pode
entender que na verdade não é uma função
complexa é uma função simples presente
na computação nas engenharias uma função
de duas variáveis percebam do lado
direito do slide é uma função de duas
variáveis variáveis x e variável y
percebam que fdx y a função de duas
variáveis aliviado mas você vem me falar
de função numa palestra do pedex a
função de duas variáveis e mais digo
mais é uma função recursiva que que é
isso uma função recursiva é uma função
que para calcular o valor dela
vocês precisam calcular primeiro valor
de outras funções
eu vou explicar imaginem
vejam lá pelo slide função de 22
vamos tentar resolver essa função parece
difícil mas não é
veja em qual situação essa função se
encaixa o x é igual ao ípsilon
rapidamente a gente pode olhar as três
situações
se ela for zero tem que se encaixar na
primeira situação onde o y é menor que o
chez ou onde o y é maior que o x e um y
é igual ao do ska ou seja o y tem que
ser par que qualquer número 1 x 2 é pá
isso se for na primeira situação mas não
é
a segunda situação onde a função é igual
a um olha só o que tem que acontecer o y
tem que ser maior que o x e um y tem que
ser igual a dois caminhos um que que
significa que o irmão tem que ser um
número ímpar porque qualquer muito num x
2 - 1 é um número ímpar
seria a segunda situação mas também não
é a terceira situação vejam lá em casa
y é igual à x e x é diferente de um
parece é essa porque na época de 22 x é
igual a 2 eo y é igual a 2 portanto nós
pegamos essa equação que vocês estão
visualizando e vamos transportar ela
para depois do sinal de igual
e aí eu só uma mera substituição de
valores quando nós substituímos os
valores vamos lá visualizar para
calcular é de 22
eu vou ter que calcular 1º f de 12 fd 1
isso é uma função recursiva é isso que
quer dizer uma função recursiva e aí
vamos então terminar popular já que a
gente chegou até aqui né já que a gente
está falando de matemática e colocando
essa função para resolver
f de 12 onde ela se encaixa rapidamente
na primeira condição porque o além
nesse caso o xi e y é menor x né aliás
disco y é maior que os x eo y é igual a
2call seja y el número pa
então nós temos a função 12 igual a zero
a função um rapidamente a gente percebe
que ela se encaixa então na segunda
situação onde o y é igual ao xxl go
portanto f-22 é igual a 1
resolvemos a função matematicamente
falando nós vamos esquecer um pouco
sobre isso agora e vamos aqui fazer uma
brincadeira e para isso já que brincar
ensina a gente quer aprender matemática
brincando eu vou convidar vocês a se
levantar e aí nós vamos começar essa
brincadeira
eu vou chamar aqui
dois voluntários que na verdade são dois
colaboradores do projeto trilha do saber
que é o andré como apoio nelson isaías
palmas para ele
primeiramente pessoal individualmente
cada um de vocês vocês vão colocar o
número um na mão direita e 10 na mão
esquerda e é uma mera transferência de
valores é como mágica
funciona mais ou menos assim quando eu
transfiro um da minha mão direita pra
minha mão esquerda a minha mão direita
fica com 10 ea minha mão esquerda fica
com um ok então vou treinar mais uma vez
bem rapidinho
olha estou vendo que estou ficando traxx
agora última vez individualmente o andré
que é mais rápido então vamos lá mais
rápido
ok agora olhem para o colega que está à
sua esquerda
esse colega ele também vai começar do
mesmo jeito que você
ele vai começar com um na mão direita e
09 esquerda então eu vou fazer o passo e
um passo 2 o passo é esse o passo 2 é
esse que nós fizemos agora acabei de
treinar com vocês e agora vou fazer o
terceiro passo que eu vou precisar do
meu colega da esquerda
então vamos lá como numa linha reta eu
vou chegar até lá no nelson que está em
último
percebam agora é a vez de vocês
todo mundo com uma lingerie preta
reserva mas que ele pode preparar
percebam que vocês começam da direita
para a esquerda eu vou continuar
tentando aqui e vocês aí
mais uma vez
de novo
uma vez mais uma vez velocidade 5
vamos ver qual é o máximo de velocidade
que a gente consegue isso aqui
aqui ok aqui bom aqui finalizamos aqui
enquanto 15 porque perfeito
olha só podem se sentar
vejamos o seguinte se nós temos uma
função como aquela uma função de duas
variáveis recursiva como eu disse nós
temos que calcular outras funções para
chegar
por incrível que pareça sem perceber
vocês calcularam uma função f 10 dez efe
de 44 f-22 vocês acabaram de calcular
uma função dessas brincando com essa
brincadeira não perceberam que chegaram
a resposta muito mais rápido do que se
nós tivéssemos feito como nesses laid
onde tem lá o passo reto de 1010 eu
teria que calcular
fd 9 dez efe de 99 depois eu teria que
calcular
fd 8 nov efe de 88 e assim
sucessivamente
vocês perceberam ak alguém que me falou
chegamos ao número 5 é justamente a
resposta de f10
talvez vocês não acreditem mas vamos
fazer o teste
vamos supor que um número x é um passo
de execução então vamos supor que esse é
o primeiro passo e vamos supor que o y é
a posição da mão
vamos lá eu vou voltar ao slide onde
demonstrava f-22 estão aqui eu estou no
primeiro passo mas eu quero é o segundo
passo é a segunda mão porque isso é de
com o resultado justamente a resposta da
função
percebam que funções como essa elas
simulam funções com as funções de
fibonacci e são funções altamente
complexas mas presentes na natureza
presente na teoria dos jogos ou seja
brincar ensina e é possível aprender não
só a matemática como muitas outras
disciplinas e tudo através da
brincadeira e aí
na verdade com isso
finalizamos aí realmente corroborando
com população de bigode que é um grande
psicólogo foi um grande a pesquisadora
pisco na psicologia do desenvolvimento e
retratou enquanto brincar é importante e
eu espero que vocês continuem brincando
e aprendendo muito tempo todos uma boa
tarde
[Aplausos]
[Música]